صانعوا السيارات الكهربائيه يتسابقون
لتصميم مركبات اقل تكلفه للجمهور لكن
مشكله العرض والطلب تتسبب في زياده
الاسعار بدلا من انخفاضها بالاضافه الى
ارتفاع اسعار بطاريات اليوتيوب بنسبه 500
في المئه خلال 2022 في نوفمبر الماضي بلغ
متوسطه تكلفه السيارات الكهربائيه الجديده
65,000$ بينما بلغ متوسط تكلفه السيارات
التي تعمل بالوقود
48.681$ قله محطات الشحن هي احدى اكبر
العوائق التي تحوله دون الاعتماد الكلي
للمركبات الكهربائيه لكن العالم يسعى
للحلول موافقت امريكا مؤخرا على خطط لبناء
محطات في جميع ولاياتها خلال الخمس سنوات
المقبله بتكلفه تقدر بخمسه مليارات عام
و20 اا افضل عام من حيث مبيعات السيارات
الكهربائيه الجديده رغم ذلك مثلت
16.6% فقط من حصه السوق بينما بلغت حصه
السيارات التي تعمل بالوقود اثنتين
واربعين فاصل ثلاثه بالمئه رغم ان تسلا هي
رائده السيارات الكهربائيه الا ان ست من
اعلى 10 سيارات كهربائيه مبيعا حول العالم
تعود لشركات صينيه